ya les he comentado en múltiples
ocasiones que la derivada evaluada en un
punto de la curva es la pendiente de la
recta tangente en ese punto de mi curva
sin embargo esta vez nuestro amigo
accord me envió un problema donde hay
que encontrar la ecuación de la recta
tangente y me di cuenta que no habíamos
hecho esto todavía entonces vamos a
hacerlo
mi problema dice lo siguiente encuentras
la recta tangente de mi curva fx igual a
equis por ea la equis en el punto x
igual a 1 y bueno antes de vendernos
como locos a resolver este ejercicio
quiero crear en ustedes un poco de
intuición de qué es lo que está pasando
así que me tomé la libertad de tomar mi
gráfica d'or y poner la función s de x
la x de x para ver qué es lo que me daba
y es esta curva de aquí en la parte de
arriba está escrita mi función
x era la x y yo lo que quiero saber es
cuál es mi recta tangente del punto x la
1 que por cierto si nosotros evaluamos
baldía fx igual a e
es decir 2.718 bla bla bla bla bla
no podemos calcular quién es efe de uno
pues f1 es igual a uno por uno
es decir 2.71 blah blah blah blah blah
por lo tanto lo que quiero es tener la
recta tangente en el punto uno como el
que es este punto de aquí 1,2 puntos 7
18 o sea por aquí mero y yo lo que
quiero es encontrar la recta tangente en
ese punto de mi curva por lo tanto vamos
a hacerlo entonces el menú va a ser el
siguiente lo que vamos a hacer es
calcular la primera derivada para
evaluarla en el punto que ya sabemos en
el punto x igual a 1 y con esto voy a
obtener la pendiente de mi recta
tangente y después utilizando lo que yo
sé de álgebra y de geometría voy a poder
resolver la ecuación de mi recta
tangente y la voy a graficar en esta
gráfica d'or entonces primero hay que
calcular la derivada de fx en el punto x
igual a 1
vamos a hacerlo fd x yo calculo su
primera derivada va a ser f prima de x
y quién es la primera derivada de x lx
bueno tienes en cuenta que es una
multiplicación de funciones por lo tanto
cuando tienen dos funciones
multiplicando x y a la equis para
calcular la derivada lo que tengo que
hacer es derivar una y multiplicarlo por
la otra tal cual y después derivar la
otra y multiplicarla por la primera tal
cual así que cuál es la derivada de x
bueno es la derivada de x es muy fácil
es 1 ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por
ea la equis y después hay que agregarle
la primera función tal cual y
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
segunda función propuesta derivada de ea
la x a puse una derivada muy padre muy
especial la derivada de l x es ella
misma
por lo tanto es x por ea la x y ya hemos
acabado la derivada ahora hay que
evaluar esta derivada en el punto x
igual a 1 para ver cuál es la pendiente
de mi recta tangente entonces vamos a
hacerlo en el punto x igual a 1 o en el
punto 1 como es entonces f prima de 1
quien va a ser pues es uno por uno
+ 1 por ea la 1 se dan cuenta toda la x
se sustituye por 1 y solamente me queda
más en que es simple y sencillamente dos
veces
o dos por 2.718 bla bla bla bla lo que
sea que sea eso pero entonces ya
encuentra la pendiente de mi recta
tangente entonces ya casi tengo la
ecuación de mi recta tangente ya tengo
la pendiente y entonces necesito saber
cuál es su ecuación ahora para esto voy
a utilizar lo que ya sabía yo en
geometría si yo tengo un punto y una
pendiente ya puedo yo saber el valor de
mi ecuación pero para esto vamos a
recordar la ecuación ordenada de origen
su ecuación era y es igual a m es la
pendiente que ya la tengo por cierto es
12 entonces es la pendiente por x + b 2
que es la pendiente x x que es la
variable independiente ya esto tengo que
agregarle b b es lo que no sabemos
entonces cómo puedo yo saber el valor
debe pues para esto necesitaría un punto
en mi curva y ya lo tengo
ya no tengo mi punto es uno coma es
decir si yo sustituyó a x por 1 y allí
por por lo tanto ya puedo saber el valor
debe darse cuenta que si yo saco el
valor debe entonces ya tengo por fin
completamente la ecuación de mi recta
entonces vamos a través del gráfica d'or
y dese cuenta el punto 1 coma
este es el punto donde yo quiero mi
recta tangente por lo tanto lo voy a
utilizar voy a sustituir ayer por el día
x por 1 y así voy a obtener a b y con
esto la ecuación de mi recta tangente
entonces cambiamos de color y ahora si
lleva lee es igual a 2 por 1 que después
2 x 1 ya esto hay que sumarle b
bien ahora voy a despejar la vez 12 por
1 pues es muy sencillo 12 por 12
y si yo lo paso restando me va a quedar
que esto es vamos hacerlo con calma
tengo es igual a 2 en más b ahora voy a
llegar a restarle de los dos lados 12
entonces me queda que es igual a menos 2
o dicho de otra manera b es igual a
menos y ya por fin tengo a b por lo
tanto ya tengo mi ecuación de mi recta
tangente ya solamente hay que sustituir
a b es decir que es igual a 2 y que
multiplica x menos en y si ustedes
quieren podrían utilizar su calculadora
para saber cuál es el valor de 2 e iu el
valor de e y sustituirlo aquí recuerden
que es un número irracional por lo tanto
no acaba sin embargo podrían ustedes
hace una aproximación y sustituirla para
no tener el valor de aquí ahora lo que
voy a hacer en este caso es poner esta
recta en mi gráfica d'or para ver
qué es lo que me sale y además con esto
voy a rectificar si realmente si obtuve
mi recta tangente en ese punto por lo
tanto que es igual a 2 por e
por equis ya esto le tengo que restar en
menos
y el resultado es ni más ni menos que
bien aquí está perfecto ya tengo mi
recta tangente fíjese que toca a este
punto a ver si a ver si lo puede ser un
poco más grande bien a toca al punto uno
cómo voy a jalar para que mi gráfica
dore perfecto y entonces yo tenía la
curva x igual a la equis que es esta
curva de aquí y yo lo que estaba
buscando en la ecuación de la recta
tangente en el punto x uno para esto lo
que hice fue primero evaluar x igual a 1
en mi función y encontré que en mi
función cuando x vale 1 f x vale y
después lo que hice fue sacar la
pendiente de mi recta tangente y para
esto ocupe la propiedad de derivar mi
función y evaluarla en el punto en el
que yo quería fue por eso aquí voy a
volver a jalar esto aquí que yo saqué la
pendiente de mi recta tangente encontré
que esa pendiente era
entonces ya tengo la pendiente me
retratan gente gracias a la derivada y
ahora yo lo que quería era encontrar la
ecuación de mi recta tangente y para
ello usted podrá álgebra y conocimiento
de la geometría y para esto lo que
utilicé fue la ecuación de la recta
tangente y saber que yo tenía el punto 1
coma
lo que hice fue sustituir la pendiente
que era igual a 12 y ayer por el día x
por 1 y así obtuve el valor debe darse
cuenta que este punto es común tanto en
mi recta tangente como en mi curva x a
la equis y por lo tanto ya solamente me
restó graficarlo para comprobar
visualmente que si era la respuesta
correcta y que en efecto era mi recta
tangente de cualquier manera espero que
este vídeo te haya sido muy útil y si lo
fue debería agradecerle a aquel que me
estuvo insistiendo bastante en realizar
un vídeo con este problema por lo tanto
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo